[Music]
so chuck it seems like we've done this
before but
you can't do it too many times and it's
it's the number one lesson
against traveling back in time what you
don't realize neil is that we've
actually done this a hundred times
before
i see what you did there yeah did you
see that yeah okay i see what you i see
what you did there
so if there were a rule book of time
travel
the number one
item
would be
you cannot go back in time
and prevent your parents from meeting
each other
because then you would have never been
born
to have gone back in time
to have prevented your parents from
meeting each other this is the
fundamental paradox
of time travel
and so
that if there were a rule book that'd be
number one rule right
here's what movie people get wrong or
they don't get it wrong they don't think
it all the way through
so what's the most famous of these
movies where they can't have somebody
get born
what's his face uh the boy that with the
hoverboard and uh
no no no no not that one
that has other rules you're not supposed
to break
down the whole thing was you gotta get
your parents to smash because if they
don't you're not born
oh right but that was gonna happen
anyway he just can't mess it up oh right
okay okay okay the point is don't go
back and stop oh terminator because you
got to stop you got to stop
okay i am looking for sarah connor i was
told that she was here
or your name is sarah connor i'll kill
you anyway
no matter
what and killed every surrogate killed
every serotonin
okay so here's the thing
so
yes you wouldn't have a terminator movie
if the terminator's sole job was to
prevent
sarah connor
from becoming pregnant
okay
that's a different movie from killing
systematically every sarah connor in the
phone book right so
and he didn't have to do that he could
go
one generation earlier
and prevent the grandparents from eating
or prevent the great grandparents from
eating or the great great great parents
i mean
anywhere in that genetic chain
if you disrupt it then you are not born
and so
introduce the great great grandmother to
a much better looking guy
and you just have a better looking time
traveling there you go this is like
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a different terminator movie
right exactly
so so i'm just saying these people think
they're on some loctite
theme
when the theme is way broader than that
in fact uh forgive me for not
remembering which movie this was it'll
come to me in a moment where
they realized that if two people
if if two people
had sex 10 minutes later than they
otherwise did
then a different sperm fertilizes likely
the same egg and that's but it's
nonetheless a completely different
person wow so even if you don't disrupt
the sex just delay it make the train
come a little later make the you know uh
have the the cup of coffee be extra
delicious so they get a second cup
before they or or the wine whatever is
the romantic forces operating that
evening
make sure they have other kids
because that will stop you from ever
being able to do it again
i mean five other kids are running
around like you got to do
you know this is just like i mean that's
what i found out during the pandemic you
know you in the house you'll be late man
we've been here for a while
what are we gonna do
every time you try to disappear they
show right up knocking on the door what
are you guys doing
what's going on in
there okay so that's a time travel movie
never never conceived see what i did
there very nicely let's see what you did
there it's
you're trying to prevent the parents
from having sex they're not having
it anyway that's it
because they've got five kids running
upside down bouncing off the walls
that's the other kids just like now
in popular parents it's called the
grandfather paradox but it's a paradox
to any one of your ancestry because
disrupting that chain will prevent you
from being born someone else could be
born now now you can you can get you can
introduce a more interesting idea
that
maybe
the forces of the timeline
care about major events
even in spite of you changing minor
events
that be an interesting fact
right i i i don't really
agree with that idea but it'd be an
interesting sci-fi so is that kind of
like inevitability so it's like even
though you change these minor things
the inevitable will still happen
correct so it could be
that you know you killed
the
some ancestor of yours so you don't
exist
but
somebody else arises in the life of the
other partner because you just have to
kill one of the partners right
that creates some other person who
basically does exactly what you were
gonna do in your life
right so it's not you but the larger
scale events still unfold and my
favorite example of this which involves
no killing at all
is if you could communicate backwards
through time
we have a hypothetical particle that
does that you know what it's called you
never hear no
it's called the tachyon oh tachyon
okay tachyon and it's uh i think it's
from the greek tacticos meaning fast
yeah the tachometer
it's the same route the tachometer which
gives you the the the
the speed of your engine uh if you're
still having a rpm
car yeah yeah the rpms that's a
tachometer so we have this hypothetical
part it's never been observed but we
sort of introduce it it's called a
tachyon
it exists moving faster than the speed
of light
and as you may remember chuck as you go
faster and faster and faster your time
slows down relative to everybody else
right at the speed of light
time stops
but what happens if you cross the speed
of light
then time goes backwards according to
the equations
so we are imagining if you could ever
accomplish this time would go backwards
for you so we introduced this particle
it's called tachyons so now you have a
tachyon texting
smartphone
okay
and your buddy's walking down the
corridor
and
you see your buddy slip on a banana peel
and fall
and you say i don't want my buddy to
slip on a banana peel and fall
so you pull out your tachyon text
message service
and you say
watch out for the banana peel
you send it to them after this event has
already happened but they receive the
text before it happens right
you got this because it moved backwards
in time right okay
so then what happens is they're walking
down the corridor
and then
the text
alert
happens okay so they pull out their
smartphone and start reading the
smartphone and it says watch out for the
banana peel
but the very fact of having pulled out
the smartphone and looked at it meant
they weren't looking down in that moment
and they slip on the banana they slip on
the peel so you caused the very event
that you thought that you were avoid uh
preventing correct
correct and that's another inevitability
scenario
that where it would declare that there's
nothing you can do about it in fact in
h.g wells's time machine
uh half the movie is weirdly in a future
that he had no clue that he thinks would
happen but the first part of the movie
the protagonist goes back in time and he
has a love interest he meets in the park
but then she gets mugged and get and
killed and he's very upset about this he
said well i got a time machine let me go
back and make sure that doesn't happen
it goes back and says don't walk this
way walk that way so she walks the other
way crosses the street gets hit by a bus
okay right and then she so
three or four ways he's trying to save
her life and then she dies every single
time and he concludes it was her it was
it was her time
that is amazing that i you know what i
didn't
remember that part of that yeah i never
read the book i actually saw the movie
um
that was only the two movies there's
original you know from the 50s or 60s
and then one
more recently in the 90s yeah so but um
what you just described is a marvel
multiverse um
doctor strange not the movie this was an
animated where dr strange is in love
with a woman who dies and he finds ways
to keep going back in time and
manipulating the timeline and she dies
in every single timeline
and so he
loses his mind he he goes insane because
he can't figure out how to save her well
okay so there's another one of these
inevitability things so we don't we
don't know we don't know for me the fact
that you existed in a past time
displacing air molecules you might have
stepped on a worm or an ant in the
street to me that's changing the
timeline right so you'd be
cherry picking all the possible all the
things that you caused and saying well
this this one is more important than the
rest
but what's the molecule say dude you
pushed me out of my way i was like there
and now i'm not there that's a different
universe as far as the molecule is
concerned it's like
so you go back in time right and you
land at a cookout
and you slap a mosquito on your neck
but that mosquito was actually on its
way
to
bite someone else that would have done
the same thing and by slapping their
neck while they were driving a car they
ran into a tree and they died and that
person ended up being
a dictator who eventually took over the
entire world
chuck i don't know where it is i don't
know where this story is going neil
[Laughter]
help me out neil
what happens i'll help you out i'll i'll
help you out there is a story where
someone goes back in time warned not to
affect not to touch anything right don't
touch it
and then he comes back and says i didn't
touch anything and the scene ends as his
foot is up on his knee and there's a
dead butterfly in the bottom of his foot
oh man and everyone
and we're all nazis because of that
butterflies
so if there was some air-currented cause
that created a monsoon and a tsunami and
a hurricane and whatever so that's it's
called the butterfly effect in reference
to that scene oh cool but anyway this
all started talking about the
grandfather paradox which could easily
be a grandmother paradox there's no
reason you have to specify gender in
this it's an ancestry paradox is oh man
you just gave it a new um term i mean
another accessory yeah let's do it
that's that's so much better the
ancestry paradox because it works
anywhere in your entire timeline that's
right yeah you got it all right chuck
it's all the time we have
this explainer absolutely that's by the
paradise now all we have is time
long as we don't touch nothing as long
as we don't touch nothing
all we got is i'm teaching you too much
see if you you think you know and then
you only know some but you think you
know all that's dangerous too
all right this has been another star
talk explainer the other guy section
always good to have chuck always a
pleasure
[Music]